Whenever you follow the commandments of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala, it is called
as ibada. It is called as worshiping
Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala.
And the most important
is the believing there is no god but
Allah. And the most important form of
worship is
salah. Then we have zakat the compulsory
charity. 2.5% of excess wealth every
lunar year more than inab level you have
to give in charity then fasting in the
month of Ramadan the full month from
dawn till sunset abstain from food water
drink and
sex then hajj if you have the
means if you have the health and the
wealth at least you should perform once
in your lifetime
Hajj that is the holy pilgrimage to the
city of
Makkah Mina Arafad
etc. These are the main pillars of
Islam. But anything what Allah
says if you follow it you're doing
ibada. If you abstain from the thing he
has prohibited you're doing ibada.
Allah says not to
have alcohol and intoxicants in Surah
Maida 5:9. If you abstain from having
intoxicants, you're doing
ibada. Allah tells us not to cheat, not
to lie. If you do not cheat, if you do
not lie, you're doing
ibada. So whatever Allah has prohibited
and if you abstain from that, it's
called as
ibada.
And if we
analyze
that every
machine it has instruction manual.
Whenever you buy a machine with the
machine comes an instruction manual. If
you buy a DVD player you'll get
instruction manual that if you want to
play insert the DVD press the play
button. If you want to forward press the
FA button. Don't drop it from height. It
will get damaged. Don't immerse it in
water. it will get
spoiled and more complicated the machine
but the more the requirement of
instruction manual. If you allow me to
call the human being the machine, you'll
have to agree that human beings are the
most complicated machine available on
the face of the earth. Don't you think
it requires an instruction
manual? The instruction manual for the
human beings is the glorious
Quran. The glorious Quran. The last and
final revelation of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala to the whole of humankind is the
instruction manual of the human beings.
The dos and don'ts of the human beings
are mentioned in the glorious
Quran.
And there are many
people who may say that why does Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala want us to praise
him? Is he hungry for praises? You know,
we say Allah abbar,
alhamdulillah, why does Allah want us to
praise him? Do you think if we say Allah
abbar, Allah will become greater? We
know Allah is already the greatest.
Whether you say Allah abbar or don't say
Allah abbar, he is already the greatest.
It will not make a difference to him at
all. So why does Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala wants us to praise him? because
he is the creator of the human beings
and he knows how does the human mind
function. He knows that the human beings
when we pray someone we follow him and
we obedient to him. For example, if your
mother has a heart attack and you and
you know there is a very famous heart
specialist and you have one person lay
man on the street. If your mother has a
heart attack, whose advice will you
take? Will you take the advice of the
heart specialist who's the most famous
in the world or will you take advice of
a lay man on the street? But naturally,
you will follow the advice of a heart
specialist. He's famous. We know that
he's number one in the world. So
similarly when we praise and say Allah
abar Allah is the greatest Allah is the
most wise Allah is the most
knowledgeable we are telling this so
that when we agree he's the most
knowledgeable most greatest we follow
his advice so Allah is asking us to
praise him for our benefit not for his
benefit